et là messieurs l'information de la
semaine n'est pas très gai l'information
de la semaine n'est pas très gai il faut
bien le dire les spécialistes sont
unanimes stéphane collaro
le festival de cannes a été un désastre
fiasco une lamentation les fines
ignominie une ignominie des français
n'ont pas été récompensés oui les jeunes
les gens s'ennuyaient les venelles sont
revenus furieuse vraie merveille
bref ce festival de cannes a été disons
le une tragédie sur rtl sur france inter
par tout le monde les spécialistes mais
le festival de cannes
oui le festival de kaka cad oui oui ça
va pas ça n'a pas été franchement je
vois notre ami notre avis qu'est-ce qui
fait la rubrique cinéma chez vous
balanga via longueur pas content du tout
chalet non un chalet furieux tous les
spécialistes et alors josé artur fou de
rage cherniak genia pas content non plus
le festival de gamme ça n'a pas été ça
cette année
et alors vous savez la lorgnette c'est
plus qu'un journal c'est c'est une
institution qui est là qui veillent
déclin attendu en france toc d'ornellas
c'est pourquoi cette semaine pour
pallier au moment du festival de cannes
alpes-maritimes la norme yen a créé le
festival de card
nous avons créé un festival de cannes un
vrai vous allez voir le d'autres
franchement je reviens de match bien
dans le nôtre tout se passe bien et
qu'on pense c'est juste d'où il ya de
l'ambiance il ya de l'ambiance les
artistes heureux de venir dans quelques
instants mesdames messieurs voici le
festival de cannes organisé par la
lorgnette ne produit que tu vas
l'international pitgam vient de
cannes tout le monde connaît c'est à 60
km de paris sur la vicinal numéro 7
s'est cannes-ecluse près de
moret-sur-loing le festival de cannes
qu'en pense d'abord l'année
comment s'est passé pour vous le
festival de cannes cette année
mon cher stéphane collaro on parle
souvent du festival de cannes
alpes-maritimes et il nous a paru quand
même juste de parler un peu de cannes
écluse
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
décidé cette année de créer et
d'organiser le premier festival de
cannes ecluse ya donc désormais deux
festivals de cannes celui de la côte
d'azur et celui ci quand même beaucoup
plus important d'après évidemment tous
les artistes que l'on a pu voir dans les
rues de cannes il est incontestable que
c'est un festival qui a le même éclat
que celui de cannes alpes-maritimes
entouré de starlettes les deux
organisateurs du festival sont ravis en
effet la situation géographique du
festival de cannes est admirable le loin
est un lieu de rêve le port des yachts
un petit miracle de goût et c'est le
président de la république en personne
qui est venu inaugurer ce festival enfin
pas lui son chien préfet
mais voici l'arrivée des vedettes
tout d'abord le faire j'ai rien je vais
observer
vous attendez pas ici à gan si vous êtes
membre du jury festival
je suis membre du jury je voudrais
mettre le président si c'était possible
quand je pense y aucun problème eddie
barclay accompagné de michel duchaussoy
toutes les vedettes font leur arrivée au
festival de cannes
l'adorable maria pacôme répond aux
journalistes
j'en peux pas y aller bon jeu c'est la
première fois vous venez à ce festival
de cannes
oui c'est la première fois et je suis
très ému et très content de voir que le
public est là que vous êtes là
puisqu'elle en liberté prisonnier de mon
succès vous êtes président du jury je
crois oui ça c'est un grand honneur pour
moi et j'espère que l'on va voter d'une
façon originale et et honnête
et voici l'enjeu du festival
international du film de cannes hic ces
coupes qui récompense les meilleurs de
la profession cinématographique
nous sommes donc dans la salle des
délibérations du jury du festival de
cannes et les présidents sont réunis
pour attribuer les prix les récompenses
de ce festival sidanse la presse
les prix de ce festival et je vais
passer immédiatement la parole au
président jean lefer jean lefebvre
quel prix avez vous attribuer le prix de
du plus grand comique internationale à
qui l'avait vu attribué à jean loup m
c'est merveilleux c'est un succès fou et
il ya deux comédiennes et à girardot ya
pas de com est en toute objectivité si
gérard dellac piétinerait pour avoir le
prix moi et m'a dit c'est pas comme
c'est pas bon on doit la place après
délibération du jury et ça a été très
difficile
nous avons donné le prix de la meilleure
mise en scène internationale à jeune
réalisateur qui est plein de promesses
qui non seulement est un acteur connu
est intéressant et qui autant théâtre
cinéma que dans le music-hall et je
crois que c'est à jean claude brialy
qu'on a donnée
présidente pauline beccari bien
le fils attention par une guêpe
claudine bégarie est une star mondiale
du film érotique qu'elle est très timide
c'est la vedette
il est at il tué le prix de l'office du
tourisme
claudine bégarie est une vedette du film
et roddick a ri et après délibération je
me suis attribuer le prix de l'orifice
quatre locaux
claudine beccari est une star mondiale
du film érotique
c'est la vedette de l'inoubliable film
exhibition mais c'est surtout ami mel et
peu doué pour la parole et jorian ce
riad le comprends fort bien bien sûr la
parole de dire ça y est j'ai décidé en
accord avec ma conscience à ses yeux et
à un acteur de talent le prix de la
meilleure interprétation gelé décerné à
michel du show oui c'est courageux c'est
courageux jorian je me suis attribué
mois le prix du meilleur acteur du
meilleur scénariste du meilleur
producteur lumière metteurs en scène
étrangers car je suis absolument
étranger à cette profession
complètement alors je tiens à dire
simplement que je ne fais ça que pour
l'argent et que mon prix est la
disposition de celui qui me
et
et c'est eddie barclay en personne qui
achète le prix de josiane sous l'oeil de
jacques tordjman ravi de participer à ce
festival en tant que producteur car il
sait qu'ici il n'ya pas de magouilles
josiane donc les plus grands moments de
votre vie
pas vraiment le nom n'ont pas vraiment
plus grands noms le plus étonnant non
plus non michel duchaussoy lui aussi
allait pas pigé mois merde alors alors
tu fais du ménage l'insee fait pas pour
qu'un reporter à la donne d'une station
des villes européennes tout cas c'est
même un canal alors que ça doit passer
sur les enseignants dont jean yanne et
tout et je me mets curial jorian genre
yade jean rien et ce que je ferai ce que
je peux passer
est-ce que je peux partir oui
jean lefebvre c'est bon vous un grand
moment
non moi je suis furieux parce qu'on
aurait pu bleus données plus tôt
je prie ya déjà dix donc j'aurais dû
l'avoir vous comprenez et si cette
concorde j'aurais voilà non non non pas
toi tu n'as pas droit
je vous en prie ne m'a pas se battre
ce modèle j'en ai eu pour la leur nid
adéquat
m
malgré quelques petits différents chacun
est heureux car le festival s'achève
merveilleusement par un repas offert à
tous les participants
le festival international de cannes
un plaisir pour tous et le sentiment du
précédent en tant que président du
premier festival international du film
de cannes je lève mon frère je lève mon
verre vers lumière
et pour mme chénel pepy si la parole est
au président briller lippi la parole est
au président barclay nous avons pensé du
cinéma français j'espère que je suis
heureux de participer à cette assemblée
où il n'a pas de métèques
cette affaire